we've talked a lot tonight about the
causes of and potential solutions to
Chicago's violence but we also want to
hear directly from a family member who
has been deeply impacted by the man even
by Chicago standards the death of 15
year old Demetrius Griffin jr. is almost
beyond comprehension
Demetrius was murdered in September 2016
and a gang had tried recruiting him
police say Demetrius was burned alive
his remains discovered in a 55-gallon
drum in an alley that's the kind of evil
the Society has had to deal with
Demetrius is aunt Rachelle Sykes joins
us now Michelle thank you for being here
I know this is so hard and I know some
of Demetrius his friends and other
families here tonight
how is Polly is mom doing
I basically she's distraught she's
basically not functioning that was her
only son that was my only nephew he was
15 years old there was nothing that he
could have done to anyone that would
want someone to do that to him he was
about four seven in height about 97
pounds they burned him alive in a copper
scam he wasn't in a gang he didn't do
drugs what is it that he could have done
so bad that a monster would take his
life like that and then two blocks from
his home we have to pass that block
every time we visit my mom I can't go
into the house without hearing him
saying TT mmm I did this TT I did that
he was looking so forward to high school
he only did two weeks of high school he
wanted to be on a swim team
he loved dogs he loved animals why would
you do that why would you burn someone
alive and then why is there such a code
of silence that you did not hear him
hollering for help and did nothing no
one saw anything
no one saw No
said they saw anything well yeah no
leads in this case at all no leads so
he's another statistic yeah and the
outrageous clearance rate in this city
meaning people not apprehended not
followed not prosecuted not jailed
yeah no suspects nothing
I am my I mean my heart breaks for you
for Polly for all of his friends
schoolmates again until you you can't
put yourself in a mother's place who has
to go through this in America right and
we were eased we did fundraising we're
still doing for andreza we raise $10,000
with the help the leaders Network as
well as an outraged citizen and then
some of the people in the area $10,000
two years $10,000
nothing sorry it's just that we have to
protect our children and if we have
people that are leaving our our city not
concerned with the protection of our
children then where we stay at as people
tonight made some new leadership in the
city yes we definitely den it's not it's
not about Democrat someone who couldn't
who notice will how to run the city
someone who cares and we call the mere
office for 30 days straight we dial 3 1
1 we call the mayor's office so get some
acknowledgement you know we still
pretending we've reached out for this
c'mere emanuel call you know we have not
heard from either one of them yet what
is that acceptable to any of you not yet
had we received a boy is burned alive
and left in a 55-gallon drum and no one
from City Hall picks up the phone and
says we're gonna find who did this until
we turn over every stone we're gonna
find who did this
well we get us think we got a revolution
Oh resolution 60 months later yeah
that's helpful
nothing not anything we did not resell
yelling for your story it's horrific as
it is is sadly repeated on the same
details not the same level of suffering
thousands of times yes and this has got
this has got to stop
thank you for being here tonight thank
you for sharing your story